اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع
واياكم في تغطيه اخر مستجدات الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب اعلن دعمه لكاظم مكارتي رئيسا
للاغلبيه في مجلس النواب حاله فوز
الجمهوريين في هذا المجلس وهو متوقع بناء
على بعض الاستطلاعات وفي الاثناء تبدا في
ختام هذه الساعه اغلاق تبدا بعض مراكز
الاقتراع باغلاق ابوابها بانتظار فرز
الاصوات واعلام النتائج وهو ما قد يتاخر
في عدد من الولايات لعده اسباب ناقشناها
في هذه التغطيه الرئيس الامريكي قد يخرج
من هذه الانتخابات خسرا كل شيء يبقى صبه
عامان ولكن اذا ما قرر الامريكيون منح
مجلسي شيوخ ونواب الى الجمهوريين فسيخسر
الاغلبيه وبالتالي سيحولون الباقي من
رئاسته الى شلل الى جمود الزميل صهيب
شرايير يسحبنا في بعض التفاصيل هذا الجانب
من الانتخابات
ما يجب ان نعرفه عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا كما تعلمون انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه تجرى كل اربع سنوات وهذا
الاختيار رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي تجرى كل سنتين
وسميت نصفيه لانها تاتي في منتصفه ولايه
الرئيس
لماذا هي مهمه الانتخابات النصفيه ولانها
في منتصف ولايه الرئيس فهي بمثابه استفتاء
حقيقي على مدى رضا الامريكيين عن اداءهم
واذا كانوا يرغبون في تعطيل قراراته
بانتخاب اغلبيه في الكونغرس من الحزب
الاخر
يتعلق الامر كله بمن يسيطر على هذا المبنى
الكونجرس يعود الامر الى عام
1787 عندما قرر واضعوا الدستور الامريكي
ان البرلمان سيكون من غرفتين وهذا ما
حصلوا عليه
الكونغرس يتكون من غرفتين مجلس النواب ب
435 مقعدا وتبقا للماده الاولى من الدستور
الامريكي ينتخب اعضاءه مجلس النواب كل
سنتين اما مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
ينتخب الشيوخ فيها ست سنوات
السباق في الانتخابات النصفيه بين الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري يكونوا على
435 مقعدا في مجلس النواب اي كامل المجلس
وخمسه وثلاثين مقعدا من مجلس الشيوخ اي
ثلث اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
كذلك ينتخب الامريكيون في هذا الثامن من
نوفمبر اعضاء المجالس المحليه وحكام 36
ولايه من اصل 50 ولايه امريكيه
الوضع الحالي الديمقراطيون لديهم اغلبيه
ضئيله في مجلس النواب منذ عام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس باغلبيه مجلس النواب
في الانتخابات النصفيه ثلاث مرات فقط اما
مجلس الشيوخ فهو منقسم بخمسين مقعدا لكل
الحزبين وسيجري التنافس على 34 مقعدا منها
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
منذ العام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس 6 مرات باغلبيه مجلس
الشيوخ وفي مره واحده فقط لم يحصل تغير
للاغلبيه في المسجد
المنظور الاوسع لهذه الانتخابات هي انها
صراع جمهوري ديمقراطي على من ستكون له
الغلبه في واشنطن لكن في سبيل هذا الهدف
الذي يسعى اليه سسته واشنطن يبدو ان
المصوتين لا يهتمون كثيرا بلون الحزب
اثناء تصويطهم بل يهتمون بشخصيه المرشح
ففي هذه الانتخابات لا نشهد موجه شعبيه
عارمه معارضه لديمقراطيين او موجه شعبيه
مؤيده عامه للجمهوريين يمكن الحديث عن
موزه حمراء او زرقاء اذا كان هناك حزب
يتفوق على الاخر باكثر من اربع نقاط مئويه
في استطلاعات الراي لكن الاستطلاعات في
السباقات الانتخابيه الانتخابيه الحاسمه
لا تمنح اي حزب التفوقا على الحزب الاخر
باكثر من اثنين في المئه
وتترجع هذه النسب منذ اسابيع لنضرب لكم
مثلا في ولايه بنسلفانيا يتنافس على منصب
كم اديموقراطيه جو شابيرو مقابل الجمهوريه
المدعوم من ترامب دوغلاسماستريانو ويتفوق
ديمقراطيه على الجمهوري باكثر من 10% في
استطلاعات الراي اي ان المقعد ديمقراطي
بشكل شبه مؤكد لكن اذا نظرنا الى منصب عضو
مجلس الشيوخ فيتنافس على المنصب
الديمقراطي جون فتورمان والجمهوري المدعوم
من ترامب محمد اوز والهامش بينهما في
استطلاعات الراي اقل من واحد بالمئه اذا
التصويت ليس حسبيا بل على شخصيه المرشح
كان فطر من متقدما في استطلاعات الراي لكن
مع ظهوره وهو يعاني اثناء الحديث بسبب
اصابته بجلطه دماغيه قبل خمسه اشهر تراجعت
حدوده اي اننا نشهد نفس الناخب في باريس
سلفانيا يصوت لحكم ديمقراطي ولكن في الوقت
نفسه يصوت لعضو مجلس الشيوخ جمهوري يدعمه
ترامب هنا تكون اهميه شخصيه
نور
ابعث لي اياها
يا وليد
من التفاصيل حول مجريات هذه الانتخابات
تنضم الينا الان مراسله تانا ريتا سليمان
من ولايه نيفادا و ناديه البلبيسي من
واشنطن واشير الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
نقرا عن استطلاعات راي عن مشاركه متساويه
بين الجنسين في الانتخابات الامريكيه وعن
ثمانيه من اصل 10 ناخبين غير راضيين عن
اداء الاقتصاد
الامريكي اضافه الى ان الناخبين وفقا
لاستطاعات راي نقلتها سيئه الان غير
راضيين عن اداء وحاله الاتحاد نبدا باخر
اخبار هذا اليوم من خلال مراقبتكم لسائر
عمليات الانتخاب وابدا معك ناديه تفضلي
طبعا ساعات تفصلنا عن اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع سنعرف ربما تفاصيل اكثر مما يسمى
بالاكزتبول اي الاشخاص الذين صوتوا بامكان
ان يسالوا لاي حزب صوته او لاي مرشح
وبالتالي يعطينا بعض المؤشرات اذا كان
بالفعل هناك سيطره متوقعه للجمهوريه على
مجلس النواب واذا كان ما يسمى كما ذكر قبل
قليل طائر وهي همم الموجه الحمراء لكن كما
ذكرنا عبر هذا اليوم واا خلال التقطيع
المستمر بانه
الامريكيين لا ي- لا يحبون لا يرغبون ب
همم ربما تسليم السلطه لحزب واحد بغض
النظر من هو هذا الحزب وبالتالي التوقعات
هو ان يكون هناك تصويت عقابي لي البيت
الابيض وقبل قليل على فكره البيت الابيض
بدا يعاد لخساره على الاقل في مجلس النواب
وسنرى ماذا سيقول الرئيس غدا همم لكن
اقتصاد بالفعل يعني حتى في اسوا الاحوال
في العاده يكون هناك تصويت ضده الحزب
الموجود في البيت الابيض سواء كان
ديمقراطي او جمهوري اوباما خسر الانتخابات
النيابيه وايضا ترامب خسرها خسرها حزب
طبعا اقصد ومن المتوقع ان يخسرها بيضا لكن
عندما نتحدث عن الخروج او التعافي من ازمه
عالميه مثل كوفد مثلا رغم ان على فكره
نسبه البطاله متدنيه وبايدن استطاع ان
يخلق عشره ملايين وظيفه لكن بالنهايه ما
يحكم عليه ان ناخذ الامريكي اليوم هل
يستطيع ان يشتري اسعار مثلا الخبز والحليب
الاشياء الكماليه يعني بنفس السعر قبل عام
او قبل سته اشهر لا وبالتالي سيصوت للطرف
الاخر بغض النظر اذا كان لديه خطه بديله
خطه افضل هو يريد التغيير لانه لا يرى بان
البلاد تسير في الاتجاه الصحيح ساعود اليك
بسؤال عن تاثيرات ذلك بعد بالليل ولكن
لنذهب الى نيفادا مع ريتا سليمان وايضا
اخر معطيات العمليه الانتخابيه كما
تراقبينها في مراكز الاقتراع عند كاليتا
بدايه
اشيل الى اخر استطلاعات الراي التي تشير
الى تقدم كبير للمرشح الجمهوري
لاكسال على منافسته الديمقراطيه كورتاز
ماستو همم لاكسالد حصل على سبعه واربعين
خاصه ثلاثه في المئه مقابل 45.9 الى
المرشحه الجمهوريه اي ما هو فارق نقطه
فاصل همم اربعه همم طبعا استطاعات الرائعه
هذه مستقله همم تابعنا عدت مراكز انتخابيه
في همم كلارك كرانتي مقاطعه كلارك همم كان
اللاست فيها استمرار تدفق الناخبين همم
بشكل ثابت وطبعا المراقبين يتوقعون زياده
في نسبه المشاركه بعد الساعه الرابعه
والنصف يعني مع انتهاء دوام العمل هنا في
هذه المقاطعه وايضا اللافت انه بثلاثه
مراكز التي تطلعناها همم كان
مشاركه اكبر
للرجال اكثر من العنصر النسائي وعندما
سالنا عن السبب اا لم يخبرنا احد لانه لا
نعلم لماذا همم ولكن همم
الانتخابات مستمره حتى اللحظه وتاسير
العمليه بسلاسه همم ليس هناك اي همم ربما
مواجهات او ربما اي اعتراضات او حوادث
حصلت في همم الانتخابات هنا في هذه
المقاطعه مع العلم انه همم العاصفه نيكل
وصلت
ستتحول الى اعصار فما يحذرون ايضا ارجو ان
تكوني بامان دائما وهذا واضح من صوت همم
الرياح همم ومن معاناتك في اثناء هذه
الرساله همم معنا رغم ذلك الا اذا رات
العاصفه غير ذلك ريتا همم يكون من العادي
ان تتركينه ولكن اتحول من جديد الى واشنطن
مع ناديه البلبيسي وتغلق على الساحل
الشرقي طبعا بعد يعني قليل بعض مراكز
الاقتراع تبدا بالاغلاق مع اختلاف التوقيت
بين ساحلين الشرقي والغربي في الولايات
المتحده ناديا كنت اريد ان اسالك كما قلت
قبل قليل عن موضوع تاثير همم معاقبه
السلطه اذا صح التعبير في الولايات
المتحده في الانتخابات النصفيه لا يعني
ذلك ايضا شللا بالنسبه الى همم اقرار
مشاريع القوانين في الكونجرس وقد فعلها
بايضا في الاشهر الاخيره ومرر العديد ولو
كان يتمتع بالاغلبيه ولكن بالتعاون مع
جمهوريين طبعا مرر العديد من القوانين
المهمه جدا بمئات مليارات الدولارات لكل
منها هذا سيعكس ايضا على الناخذ بالنتيجه
وعلى علاقته بوضعه الاقتصادي لانه سيشل
السلطه للجمهوريين
مره اليس كذلك
يعني الى حد ما بس عاده في الانتخابات
الناخب يصوت كما كل ظالم ربما لديه ذاكره
سياسيه ضعيفه نوعا ما لانه اليوم هي فرصته
لتغيير على الاقل مسار البلاد لكن بشكل
عام اكيد يعني اذكر بمشكله رئيس الاغلبيه
الذي كان في مجلس الشيوخ كان يقول ساجعل
كان يقولها يعني علنا ساجعل الرئيس اوباما
رئيسا للولايه واحده فقط وبالتالي هذا
الاستقطاب والانقسام معروف في واشنطن منذ
سنوات يعني لكن تعميقه سيكون اكثر في
سنتين القادمهتين وخصوصا وانها ليس فقط
استفتاء بالنسبه لسير العمليه سير البلاد
والقضايا التي وصلت على الامريكي لكن
استفتاء على الرئيس وعلى من هو المرشح
الجمهوري القادم طبعا هناك همم كما تعرف
ترامب يريد ان يخبرنا بانه يوم الثلاثاء
القادم ربما هو سيترشح لكن بالنهايه ليس
قد الجمهوريين الى سيطروا على مجلس النواب
الذي يتحكم بالميزانيه بالدرجه الاولى
يمكن ان يعطلوا كل مشاريع بعض يعني انسى
اي مشروع يمكن ان يمرر لكن ايضا يمكن ان
يعكس بعض المشاريع التي مررها بامكان من
يفعل ذلك وهذه مشكله همم الاستقطاب الحزبي
او السياسي لم يعد هناك ما رايناه قبل 20
عاما فقط
20 عاما الى الوراء عندما يعود
اليكولورادو
الاصوات
اليك بعد قليل مباشره لاحد مراكز الاقتراع
في كولورادو حيث بدات بالفعل عمليات فرز
الاصوات في هذه العمليه الانتخابيه
الدائره على قدم وساق في جميع اراضي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانتظار ان
يبدا العدوى الفارس في جميع الولايات ولكن
مع اختلاف توقيت من اجل اختيار اعضاء مجلس
النواب الجدد وعدد من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
اضافه الى حكام ولايات في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ونحن نتابع هذه الصور
نتابع مع ريتا قبل ان نعود الى نادي ايضا
ريتا اريد ان تصفي لنا ما اختلف عليك
شخصيا عندما كنت تغطين في الاستديو من
بعيد مثل هكذا انتخابات لسنوات طويله
ولعدد من الانتخابات السابقه وما شهدتيه
على الارض ربما في العالم العربي عاده
تاخذنا الكثير من
انطباعات ربما المبالغ فيها او الخاطئه
احيانا عن هموم الناخب الامريكي نربطها
دائما بمشاكلنا نحن وهم بعيدون جدا عن هذه
المشاكل مثلا لمثل هذه الناحيه او غيرها
ما الذي اختلف عليك
لقد لمست بلمس اليد تفاصيل دقيقه لم كنا
نجهلها تماما كنت اجهلها انا شخصيا فيما
يخص
الامريكي والخاصيه الامريكيه للانتخابات
كنا دائما ما نربط الوضع الامريكي
بالاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه ولكن الوضع
اختلف تماما ناخذ الامريكي غير مهتم تماما
بالسياسه الخارجيه همم اهتمامات محصوره
داخليا همم بشكل شخصي همم له همم فقط ما
اختلف ايضا التفاصيل الاخرى حيث تعرفنا
على سياسات همم اختلفت وجهه نظرنا ان كان
من الناحيه كل ولايه لها خاصياتها تختلف
عن الولايات الاخرى همم تعرفت على قوانين
الفيدراليه الامريكيه كل هذه التفاصيل
طبعا بمساعده همم زملائي في مكتب واشنطن
فكانت دائما تحاول ان تقنعنا بذلك في كل
انتخابات انه الامريكان عندهم مشاكلهم
الخاصه مس فقط مشاكل العالم العربي بس ما
كنا نسمع منها للاسف ههه ناديه سؤال اخير
اساله اليك عن
نشهد لهلا ههه عن مدى تمكن ان الناخب
الامريكي او الاحزاب الامريكيه التقليديه
النافذه حزب الديمقراطي الحزب الجمهوري من
انتاج نجوم جدد لهم شخصيات جديده عانا همم
الحزب الديمقراطي في فتره والحزب الجمهوري
في فتره اخرى من انتاج هذه النجوم وهذه
الشخصيات الى اين تستطاع في هذه
الانتخابات ان همم يعني
يتفادى ذلك
يعني ننسى انه هذه ليست بانتخابات رئاسيه
معروفين هم الاشخاص الذين يمثلون الاحزاب
لكن الملفت هو ااا يعني قدره الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب على التحكم في مصير
الحزب الجمهوري ودعم بعض المرشحين هم غير
مؤهلين اصلا مثلا ما ميت اوز الذي كان له
برنامج توك شو يعني همم وكان شخصيه معروفه
لكنه غير البعض يقرا لانه غير مؤهل على
الاطلاق ان يكون في يمثل في مجلس الشيوخ
انتقل من نيويورك الى بن سلفانيا دعامه
الرئيس ترامب وعلى العديد يعني اعطيك
امثله كثيره بالنهايه هناك تغيير في
الطبقه النخبه اذا اردت ان يعني التقليدي
التقليد المعروف بانه الذي يترشح لمجلس
الشيوخ لديه خبره وكانت عسكريه او
دبلوماسيه او سياسيه الان نرى مثلا هارشي
وبوكا كان لاعب كره قدم سابق دعمه هو رئيس
ترامب اذا نجح قد ياتيمثل ولاد جورجيا في
مجلس هناك تغيير كبير لكن العجز في
القياده ينطبق ايضا على الحزب الديمقراطي
يعني هناك من يرى بانه اذا خسر
الديمقراطيون الليله في المجلسين هناك بعض
الاصوات التي ستطلب من الرئيس التنحي
جانبا وان يعطي الفرصه لشخص اخر لكن من هو
هذا الشخص هناك ايضا اعز ربما في القياده
بالعالم كله اذا نظرنا على دول مثل
ايطاليا وفرنسا وبريطانيا وغيرها يعني
وكانه العالم لم يعد يستطيع ان ينتج او
يقدم لي الناخب او للشعب بشكل عام همم
ربما جيل جديد صاعد يمكن ان يعبر عن مطالب
عن امال وان يكون مؤهل يعني اثنين لا يجب
ان يتعارضا لكن على الاقل في الحزب
الديمقراطي هناك من يتحدث عن همم كان مرشح
سابق للانتخابات الامريكيه الرئاسيه
السابقه وهناكرون ديسانتوس اللي هو حاكم
فلوريدا المتوقع ان يترشح عن حزب الجمهور
طبعا اذا لم يستطيع الرئيس ترامب ان يطيحه
ارضا لانه لا يطيقه على الاطلاق وبدا الان
حمله ضده وبالتالي هو يقبض بيديه وبقبضه
على الحزب الجمهوري ويتحكم فيه بشكل كبير
لولايه رئاسيه ثانيه ناديه البلبيسي
مراسله العربيه من واشنطن سليمان من ولايه
نيفادا شكرا جزيلا لكما على كل هذه
المعلومات ونتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام
فيما لدينا من اخبار وقصص عددناها لهذه
التغطيه اعاده تقسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه
ايضا عمليه معقده لكنها مفصليه وتعتمد على
معايير عده قد ترجح كافه حزب على اخر في
القبرص
مفهوم اساسي تقوم عليه الانتخابات
التشريعيه الامريكيه يعرف باعاده تقسيم
الدوائر الانتخابيه
ويستند الى تعداد سكاني يجرى كل عشر سنوات
بحيث يكون لكل منطقه ممثلا واحد على الاقل
يمثل عدد السكان
اعادته رسم حدود المقاطعات ثاني خسارته او
ربح نحو ثلاثه عشره ولايه لمقاعده في
الكونغرس اعتمادا على التغير السكاني فيها
فبعد التعداد السكاني الاحداث قل عدد
الدوائر التنفسيه بين الاحزاب بشكل عام
واقتصرت على 34 من ثقافه فقط وذلك بما
معدله 17 منطقه اقل من ما كانت عليه عند
استخدام الخرائط السابقه هذه المناطق ال
17 حلت مكانها 9 مقاطعه جمهوريه وثمانيه
مقاطعه ديمقراطيه ولعب التكساس دورا كبيرا
في تراجع المناطق التنفسيه فكانت تحوي 11
منطقه كنا جمهوريين اعدوا رسم الخريطه
لتبقى واحده فقط
واثبتت التجارب التاريخيه استفاده الحزب
المسيطر على المجالس التشريعيه في
الولايات من ترسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه
وبالفعل سيطره مجالسه تشريعيه ذات اغلبيه
الجمهوريه على نحو 30 ولايه اعطتهم الكلمه
الاخيره بشان اعاده تقسيم الدوائر في 177
دائره بالكونجرس يذكر ان بضع ولايه بينها
الاسكا ومونتانا وفيلمونت لا تتبعوا
قوانين اعاده تقسيم الدوائر لامتلاكها
ممثلا واحدا فقط
شكرا لروان على هذه التقارير لتغطيه
الانتخابات ونتابع في نقاش بعض جوانبها من
واشنطن ديفيد رمضان استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جورج مايسون اهلا بك
معنا دكتور ديفيد في هذه التغطيه وانا
اريد ان ابدا معك بالنقاش خاصه بشان موضوع
متعلق بمن ينتخب الامريكي اليوم كان
الحديث دائما عن حزبين ولكن تصديا بالكثير
من المسميات واتهامات متبادله بينهما
الحزب الديمقراطي يتهم
الجمهوريين بالترمبيه احيانا وبالذهاب الى
اقصى اليمين والعكس بالنسبه الى
الديمقراطيين يتهمون بالذهاب الى اقصاء
اليسار خاصه وفقتها مات دونالد ترامب
واتباعه لهم همم هل تصدى الحسبان وبات
الناخب الامريكي غير مقتنع تماما بكليهما
وربما هذا يؤسس لانتاج همم نخبه سياسيه
جديده تكون الولايات المتحده ماذا فعلا
اليها
نعم شكرا للاستضافه لا للاسف هذا الشرخ
وهذا الوجود
للمتحذبين همم
الاكستريم بنسميهم على على الجانبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري زاد من قوه الحزبين
خاصه في انتخابات الكونغرس اليوم الناخب
الامريكي ينتخب الحزب وليس الشخص وراينا
ذلك همم بحسب الاشخاص اللي نزلوا ممات اوز
ال- ال- المرشح
لمجلس الشيوخ همم الشخص التليفزيون
المشهور لا يمثل فكر سياسي بل يمثل حزبه
همم
انه بالعكس الناخب قد يلجا احيانا الى
شخصيه تجذب بعيدا عن حزبه او بغض النظر عن
الحزب الذي يمثل بدليل انه في شخصيات
تقلبت بين الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
همم في في مسار حياتهم السياسيه
نعم ولكن ولكن
كسبوا الصوت الحزبي اليوم سيربح حسب حسب
التصورات وحسب التحليلات وحسب استطلاعات
الراي سيربح الحزب الجمهوري
الكونجرس همم
بالمجلسين مجلس نواب ومجلس الشيوخ وذلك
للصوت الحزبي الذي يصوت للحزب وليس للشخص
واقر واقر في في جورجيا سيربح من من
المتوقع انه يربح اليوم مجلس الشيوخ مع
العلم انه حياته السياسي ليست موجودي
وحياته الشخصيه همم بعكس تماما ال- ال-
الاسس للحزب الجمهوري ههه
يعني انت تريد ان تقول بحكم الاستقط
الشديد الذي حصل لذلك الصوت المؤثر في هذه
الانتخابات سيكون الصوت الداعم الصوت
الحزبي المتشدد اذا صح التعبير بين قوسين
الذي لا يهم ما يقول الحزب الاخر ولكن
عنده قناعه كامله باداء حزبه بغض النظر عن
الشخصيات التي يقدمها
الحزب الاخر لا يهموا شو بقول الشخص اللي
نزل على الانتخابات لا يهموش السيره
الذاتيه للشخص لا يهمه شو كانت شو كانت
تاريخه لهالشخص المهم اليوم هالشخص هذا
منتسب للحزب الشخص هذا بيجيب الفوق لوحده
وخمسين بمجلس الشيوخ لذلك سننتخبه بغض
النظر اذا كان هذا شخص موفق او لا اذا كان
عنده البعد السياسي او لا حتى من العين
في الانتخابات الديمقراطيه تمام الحاكم
السابق في ولايه التنس الفنيه الذي تعرض
لوعك صحيه ومن المفروض انه غير قادر على
على ممارسه الحياه
السياسيه
بعد ما رجع 100% عم يقرا كل شيء على
التلفزيون
ما قادر يعبر عن عن اراء ومن دون ما
يقراها همم هذه الفكره وصلت بس انا اريد
ان اتابع معك في نقطه وتعلق همم لتغير
المزاج الشعبي بتغير مزاج الناخب الامريكي
همم هل هو متغير بهذه الديناميكيه السريعه
بهذه السرعه كل عامين الى اربعه اعوام
يعني كل عامين يعاقب السلطه وياتي بحزب
جديد لكي يشارك السلطه الحكم السلطه
التنفيذيه المتمثله بالرئيس وكل اربع
سنوات يعني ليس كل اربع سنوات احيانا ياتي
رئيس لولايتين ولكن ايضا قد يغير الرئيس
هل هو مزاج همم متقلب ام الى ما ترجع ذلك
ليس مزاج متقلب هو مين عم يجي وبصوت اليوم
مين ما عم بسوي
الحزبيين يقومون بالتصويت خلال هذه
الانتخابات اكثر من الاشخاص الغير
متحذينس المستقلين
عددهم هيكون قليل جدا في الانتخابات
النصفيه
بيطلعوا بالانتخابات العامه انتخابات
الرئاسيه اكثر من الانتخابات النصفيه
ولذلك بتلاقي الحزب الاخر الحزب اللي منه
موجود بالسلطه بتلاقي مناصرين وهن اللي
هيطلع واللي هيصوتوا اكثر من غيره اليوم
وبما انه هن راح يطلعوا صوتوا اكثر من
غيرهم تقله بالانتخابات وبياخذوا من
السلطه ليكون في بالانس ليكون في ميزان
للثقل همم في واشنطن ليس تغيير في الراي
بل العدد اخر من الناخبين اللي يشترك
اليوم في الانتخابات بينما عدد كبير من
الامريكيين لا يشترك في الانتخابات اليوم
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التفاصيل ديفيد
رمضان استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
جرش ميسون شكرا دكتور على هذه المشاركه
تحياتي اليك نتابع واياكم ايضا في هذه
التغطيه ولكن بعد الفاصل فارجو ان تبقى
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد يدخل الرئيس الامريكي
الانتخابات النصفيه وهو يضع حزبه في موقف
صعب للغايه شعبيه الرجل اخذه في التاكل
والسبب الرئيسي يعود الى الاقتصاد نقطه
ضعفه الكبيره قبل الانتخابات انتقد بيضا
قرار اوبك بلس بخفضه انتاج النفط ذلك لانه
حاول خفض الاسعار ليدخل الانتخابات وبيده
وراء قرار راحه دون الانتفاض الى الحاجه
الحقيقيه للسوق ومصلحه الاقتصاد العالم
ازمه امريكا مع النفط بدات مع دخول
الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر الرئيس
السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفيدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله ثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا ايضا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
ادارته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعد الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا تواجه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
ارتفاع الاسعار في الولايات المتحده يعود
الى نقص القدره على تحويل النفط الى وقود
وبالتالي تراجع المعروض في السوق الداخليه
بالارقام شكل الهامش بين اسعار النفط
الخام والمنتجات المكرره نحو 20 دولارا
نقلتها الحرب الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين
الدولارات
عامل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه
السيئه بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغه بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب بتوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتي التكرير فيها ايضا
يعود انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق
المصافي بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم
تعد مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
بحث لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال
الذي وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلوبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
الدورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
الطاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمه الاسعار
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسي بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم
معنى من واشنطن دكتور فراس مقصد استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جورج واشنطن
اهلا بك معنا دكتور فراس مره جديده على
شاشه العربيه ونحاول ان نفهم معك اكثر
موضوع التغييرات التي تطرا على المشهد
السياسي الامريكي عندما يتعلق الموضوع
بالانتخابات كل اربع سنوات وكل عامين بشكل
نصفي هذا ما الذي يجب ان يعنيه بالنسبه
الى العالم على الاقل الى بالنسبه الى
عالمنا العربي عندما يتعلق بالتعاطي معه
في عديد السياسات المهمه النفطيه وغيرها
لانه همم الجمهوريون يختلفون بسياساتهم عن
الديمقراطيين والعكس وهذا زاد في الفتره
الاخيره
نعم شكرا طاهر للاستضافه علينا تفكير اولا
ان حسب دستور الولايات المتحده اييه اتخاذ
القرار القرارات المتعلقه بصياغه وصناعه
اييي الصناعه السياسه الخارجيه للولايات
المتحده هي من صلاحيات الرئيس وهي من
صلاحيات الرئيس والبيت الابيض السلطه
التنفيذيه ولكن الاهميه اين في هذه
الانتخابات الاهميه ان السلطه التشريعيه
الكونجرس لديه
السيطره على كيفيه استخدام
الاموال الاموال الناخبين الامريكيين الذي
اموال الضرائب ومن هنا هذا تاتي بالكثير
من السلطه
الشيوخ ومجلس النواب وتغذي يستطيع مجلس
الشيوخ مجلس النواب مجتمعين ان يكون لهم
نفوذ على قرارات الرئيس وما يحصل عندما
يكون هنالك انتخابات نصفيه كمان ارا اليوم
وتفرز هذه الانتخابات نتيجه يكون هنالك
سيطره من الجمهوريين من جهه في في
الكونغرس الامريكي وبيت ابيض همم
للديمقراطين همم يحصل جريدلوج اهي همم
الماشينري الصناعه القرار هنا في واشنطن
همم
يبتسم بالجمود واعتقدنا اشهده في السنتين
المتبقيتين من اداره بعد ان هناك الكثير
من الاخت هو الرد والتحقيقات من الكونجرس
همم التي تستهدف الرئيس شخصيا والمقربين
منه والبيت الابيض ولكن
صناعه القرار الخارجي هي ما زالت من
صلاحيات الرئيس طبعا وهو وزاره الخارجيه
وزاره الدفاع تمام ولكن على همم صعيد
صياغه هذه القرارات الخارجيه كان هناك
الكثير من التاثير العكسي اذا صح التعبير
هل يمكن ان نتفق ونقول انه بعض القرارات
الدوليه الاخيره التي اتخذت كان لها اثر
سلبي على ما اراده وايضا مثلا في موضوع
النفط عندما اتخذت اوبك بلس قرارها بخفض
الانتاج على عكس ما كان يريده بيضا لا بل
واتهمت بعض الاصوات الامريكيه ال- ال-
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعديد الدول
المنتميه الى اوبك بالوقوف الى جانب روسيا
في هذا المجال حاولت ان تدول القضيه اكثر
من ربطها بالانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
الى اي مدى كان ذلك عاملا مؤثرا باعتقادك
في الداخل الامريكي
طاهر هنالك مقوله شهيره في الولايات
المتحده عندما يتعلق الموضوع بالانتخابات
جيمس كار في دي كانت كبار المستشارين
للرئيس السابق كان يقول
انه الاقتصاد دائما الاغتصاب هو الموضوع
والملف الاول على ذهن الناخب الاميركي ومن
هنا كانت هنالك محاوله براي انها غير
ناجحه اللي الرئيس ان يقول ان المشكله لم
تكن سوء اداره من
ادارته هي المشكله كانت في الخليج العربي
وبالتحديد رامي كره النار تجاه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكن الكل هنا يدرك ان
مشكله همم اداره
بالتعامل مع هذا الملف هو ان هناك
وهذه الايديولوجيا تريد ان ان تشيطر كل ما
يتعلق بشركات النفط اذ كانت امريكيه او
عالميه بينما ليس هنالك الجسر للعبور
للمنت المتجدده للطاقه وهنالك فتره
انتقاليه يحتاج العالم ان يمر بها ولكن
هذه الشيطنه لشركات النفط والدول المصدره
للنفط هنالك هنا في الولايات المتحده طبعا
عند الديمقراطيه من يصدق هذه الروايه ولكن
هنالك الكثيرين وبالاخص رجال الاعمال
والمثقفين يدركون امام هذه المشكله في
السماء
دكتور فيما يتعلق بعالمنا العربي لبعض
يريد ان يعرف يعني يسمع عن الجمهوريين
وقراراتهم وعن الديمقراطيين المشاهد في
منزله يريد ان يعرف من الذي يهتم بالعلم
العربي حقيقه من الاقرب الى تصوراتنا والى
قضايانا الحزب الديمقراطي الديمقراطي او
الجمهوري بقياداتها تاريخيه وفقا للسوابقه
التي حصلت في هذا المجال اما انه الامر
سيان بالنسبه الى الحسبين عندما يتعلق ليس
طبعا بمصلحه الولايات المتحده همم هي فوق
كل الاعتبار بالنسبه اليهم ولكن على الاقل
بالنسبه الى قضايانا
نعم طاهر هنالك
تيار شعور
رغبه انعزاليه لدى الناخب الامريكي في
خلال حزب يعني اذ كان جمهوري او ديمقراطي
نحن نعلم ان الرئيس اوباما هو اول من قال
سننهي هذه الحروب حروب التي لا نهايه لها
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اي افغانستان
والعراق وكانت اصلا دول المنطقه هي بغنى
عن هذه الحروب وكان ضدها اصلا ولكن هذه
الاخفاقات الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط اسست لراي عام امريكي مشترك ما بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين لا يريد تدخل او
لا يريد سياسه امريكيه همم موجوده ويعني
متشدده لمصلحه هذه الدول والشركاء في
المنطقه العربيه ولكن طبعا طبعا في العامل
الشخصي والعامل الايديولوجيا ما زالوا
متفاهمين اكثر للحلفاء في المنطقه العربيه
جزيلا لوجودك معنا الليله دكتور فراس مقصد
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جورج
واشنطن شكرا لهذه الشروحات تحياتي اليك
نتابع من الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي شق طريقه
ايضا الى هذه الانتخابات الامريكيه وسخدم
بشكل كبير الا انه يرتبط بمخاوف عده اهمها
ما يتعلق بشق الامني متابعه
حتى ابتكارات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
الانتخابات الامريكيه النصفيه والرئاسيه
المجال امام الحملات السياسيه لتحديد
الناخبين والجمع التبرعات والبيانات بصوره
سريعه واعتبر الحزب الديمقراطي الذكاء
الاصطناعي سلاحه الخارق ولجا اليه في الف
حمله ديموقراطيه ولجنه سياسيه في انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه هناك حوالي 300 مرشح
لجؤوا للذكاء الاصطناعي في حملاتهم في
مجلس الشيوخ والنواب مع ذلك يعد الذكاء
الاصطناعي سلاحا ذا حدين فراغ مس سهوله
وسرعه وصوله للناب وحصر الاصوات الا انه
يواجه اشكالات عده على راسها الرقابه
وحمايه البيانات والعيوب الامنيه وبحسب
خبراء امنيين لا يطلب من موردي تكنولوجيا
للانتخابات الابلاغ عن الخروق الامنيه او
فحص الخلفيات الموظفين او الابلاغ عن
الملك الاجنبيه امر يلفت النظر الى مخاوف
تتعلق بالهجمه السيبرانيه التي تستهدف
انظمه التصويت
بحسب بوليتيكو تستخدم عمليات التصويت في
الانتخابات النصفيه اجهزه المودم لارسال
بيانات التصويت سريعا من الدوائر
الانتخابيه الى المكاتب المركزيه باستخدام
شبكات هواتف محموله بعضها قد يكون غير
محمي امر يفتح باب قد يستغله القراصنه
لسرقه او تزوير البيانات دون الحاجه
للوصول للالات بشكل المادي وهو السيناريو
الذي لجا اليه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في التشكيك بنتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
عام 2020
وفي عام 2019 وبعد التدخل الروسي السيراني
بانتخابات عام 2016
اوسط لجنه المخابرات بمجلس الشيوخ بان
يقوم المسؤولون بازاله او تعطيل اي قدره
للشبكات اللاسلكيه في الالات التصويت
وحذرت ولايه عده استخدام اجهزه المدن
بالتصويت لكن البداء الى الرئيسيه ليست
الافضل فعمليه توصيل الاصوات عبر البريد
المركزي او العد اليدوي عمليه تحمل الخطا
وتستغرق وقتا اطول بكثير
في طوكيو 20 20 حصد رياضيون الولايات
المتحده
113 ميداليه لتتصدر ترتيب ميداليات
الاولمبياد الصيفيه لكن ماذا عن علاقه
الانتخابات الامريكيه بالالعاب الاولمبيه
ثم تتقارب بين الانتخابات في الولايات
المتحده والدورات الاولمبيه على اقل تقدير
من المنظور الزمني في عالم السياسه حول
انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه كل اربعه
اعوام وفي عالم الرياضه يكون هذا العام
موعدا اقامه دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه
الصيفيه
فاذا عدنا الى عام 2012 نجد ان المرشحين
ميتروني من الحزب الجمهوري وبراك اوباما
من الديمقراطيين تنافس على الوصول الى
البيت الابيض في ذات العام كان يصيب بولت
يواصل كسر ارقامه القياسيه مع جامايكا في
اولمبياد لندن
2016 عندما كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
محتدمه بين دونالد ترامب كلينتون حصد
السباح الامريكي مايكل فيلبس في اولمبيات
ريو دي جانيرو 5 ميداليات ذهبيه ليصبح
ابرز رياضي في التاريخ اذا تقام
الانتخابات الرئاسيه كل اربعه اعوام
بالتزامن مع الالعاب الصيفيه وتقطع نصف
مده الرئيس الامريكي التي تبلغ اربعه
اعوام انتخابات التجديد النصفي كذلك الحال
في الالعاب الاولمبيه الصيفيه حيث تقطعها
في نصف مدتها دوره الالعاب الشتويه وفي
2014 خلال تشديد النصفي عندما سيطر
الجمهوريون على الكونجرس بغرفتي كانت تجرى
دوره الالعاب الشتويه في سوتشي التي احتل
فيها الرياضيون الامريكيون المركز الرابع
وفي 2018 خلال التجديد النصفي حافظ
الجمهوريون على الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
بينما ذهبت اغلبيه مجلس النواب
للديمقراطيين هذا التوازن
ظهر في دوره الالعاب الشتويه المقامه في
كوريا الجنوبيه لي حافظ الامريكيون على
المركز الرابع للدوره الثانيه على التوالي
اكتمت دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه
2022 في بكين خلال فبراير الماضي ولم تشهد
مشاركه الولايات المتحده بسبب مقاطعتها
الدبلوماسيه من جانب اداره الرئيس
الامريكي
الاداره التي تواجه سباق الانتخابيه صعبه
مع الجمهوريه
صهيب معكم في ساعه المقبله من التغطيه الى
اللقاء